what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight predictions video there are a few
things I want to say before I actually
get into the predictions you may feel
like you're having deja vu when you're
watching this video because I am sure
most of you have heard me say some of
these things in the past but I will tell
you why you are hearing them again today
I am sure some of you are aware of HBO's
recent crackdown on a lot of Game of
Thrones channels that use copyrighted
content like pictures or video clips
that are too long from the show
personally I've had over 60 of my videos
demonetised with copyright claims put on
them but over the past few weeks I have
been able to get most of those claims
overturned because what I use on my
videos is considered fair use but
unfortunately a lot of people's videos
were flagged anyway because they made
some kind of adjustment to their system
that puts claims on videos but the good
thing is out of those 60 videos they
flagged on my channel I was able to get
over 40 of them monetized again but
there are still a handful of videos that
I won't be able to challenge so I took a
few of those videos down from my channel
and instead of just deleting all that
work I decided to cut them up into
pieces and I turned it into this video I
thought about just leaving them down or
making them private but since I already
spent so much time making them I figured
I should at least keep some of those
predictions and just put it into this
one video but don't worry this will be
the only time I do that because all the
videos on my channel do fall under fair
use now which allows me to use photos
and video footage from Game of Thrones I
will be right back to my normal upload
schedule tomorrow and I want to thank
all of you who left me some great
questions on the community tab I have
already started working on that video
and it will be uploaded tomorrow but I
did feel like I should put this
disclaimer at the beginning of the video
because I didn't want some of you to
think I was trying to pull a fast one on
you because trust me the last thing I
want to do is reload a video but I do
hope you enjoy this nonetheless so let's
begin so first I want to talk about the
relationship between Jon Snow and
Daenerys Targaryen as we saw in the
season 7 finale John and Danny have
honored the Targaryen tradition by
keeping it all in the family ever since
season 1 Daenerys has assumed she can no
longer
children and they have made sure to
remind us of this several times in the
last few episodes but I think it's quite
clear now that Daenerys will in fact get
pregnant anyway as I have said in my
last video I believe death will pay for
life which will allow Daenerys to get
pregnant once again but not only will
she get pregnant I believe she will have
John snows child some of you said since
John Snow is a Targaryen and Daenerys is
a Targaryen that could be the perfect
ingredients I should say that would
allow for this to happen some of you
have also said since John Snow has died
it was his death that would actually pay
for life and that's what will cause
Daenerys to get pregnant personally I
still think it's because of vissarion's
death
I think Daenerys had to lose something
close to her for her to be able to pay
for life but I do like the idea about
Daenerys needing to breed with another
Targaryen to allow her to have children
I do think that is a very good candidate
but now you have to wonder about their
relationship moving forward we just got
a massive revelation thanks to brain
stark and Samwell Tarly Rhaegar and
Lyanna were married and this makes Jon
Snow a legitimate Targaryen and rightful
heir to the Iron Throne putting him in
front of Daenerys Targaryen same this
news is going to completely change the
face of the politics in Westeros
although the Great War is here this is
going to make Dany and John's
relationship very awkward if the Narus
is in fact pregnant John is gonna have
to make a tough decision we know that
John is not gonna want a child of his
being born a bastard that was the whole
reason he was still a virgin in the
first place he told Sam the reason why
he never slept with Ross was because
what if he got her pregnant then there
would be another bastard named snow she
was up there in the brothel as ROS took
off her clothes but I couldn't do it
because all I could think was what
difficulty are pregnant she had a child
another bastard named snow knowing how
John felt about this he will want to
marry Daenerys if he knows she is
pregnant with his child but can you
imagine how the north and possibly even
sons that would feel about all of this
happening at once as of right now no one
else knows the truth about Jon Snow's
parents in his claim for the Iron Throne
except for Brian Sam and Howland Reed we
have seen the north ready to revolt
against John now that he has left them
to go south and greet with a Targaryen
but we have also seen how the show is
changing as it heads towards its endgame
almost all the characters are learning
to accept others no matter their
differences in their past conflicts now
that the Great War is here all of that
has to be put to the side in order for
everyone to come together and defeat the
knight King this is something that's
gonna have to continue happening if
everybody wants to survive
now that the knight King is coming south
I'm not so sure if the northerners are
gonna even have time to question Jon
Snow or Daenerys I also think once they
learn what Daenerys has sacrificed to
help them they will be more
understanding and willing to work
together they really don't have a choice
they're gonna have to accept Daenerys
for who she is and Jon Snow for who he
is when this big revelation comes out
and becomes public knowledge I could see
some of the northerners being upset and
angry and leaving but they will not
survive the winter if they choose to do
that the first thing we will see is the
night king completely destroying the
Nights Watch then I believe he will head
to Winterfell and that's where we will
see a huge war as everyone tries to
defend it like I have said before I
think the Nights Watch will no longer
have a purpose after the Great War is
over with the wall being destroyed in
everything that was north of the wall
now being south already there will be no
reason to have a Night's Watch anymore
if the night King and the army of the
Dead get defeated there will be nothing
left north of the wall that they will
need to protect the realm from as of
right now Cersei is the only one not
willing to play ball even though she
knows the threat is real she was given a
demonstration with the one white but she
still doesn't understand how serious
this threat actually is this is going to
severely complicate things for Jon and
Daenerys not only because they will not
have the Lannister
helping them but sir see now has
reinforcements on the way from Essos so
John and Daenerys could potentially be
facing an army on two different fronts
Jamie has finally woke up and realized
he can no longer stand by Cersei side
and support her madness Jaime's decision
to leave is also very interesting
because you have to wonder where he is
going to be going winter is now reaching
King's Landing so I can only imagine how
harsh the weather is going to be going
as he heads north but how will Jamie get
greeted when he arrives we know that Jon
and Daenerys was willing to put aside
their differences to fight together with
the Lannisters but John has no idea that
it was actually Jamie who pushed Bryan
out of the tower window at Winterfell
brain did have a mash up version of
visions a few seasons ago and one of
those visions was him falling out of the
tower
but he still didn't see who pushed him
[Applause]
the only two people alive right now that
know this for a fact is Theon and
Brienne lady Catelyn was telling people
that the Lannisters were responsible for
this but all of those people are now
dead but Breen knows and she is in the
North but I don't see Bree and ever
snitching on Jamie I think she still
loves Jamie too much to see him be put
in a position of possibly being executed
for crippling Brian so I want to ask all
of you this everybody that is watching
and listening to this right now leave a
comment down below and let me know what
you think will happen with Jamie when
and if he makes it to Winterfell what
will happen if Brian Stark reveals the
truth about Jamie pushing him out of the
window let me know what you think about
that down below another interesting
thing to note about Jamie heading north
is now we are gonna have all the
Valyrian steel in one general place and
this was something I had talked about
before too
this isn't a coincidence now that the
Great War is here we're gonna need all
the Valyrian steel in this war being put
to use all of the Valyrian steel swords
in the show are now right where they
belong
Jamie also knows those swords were made
from Ned Stark's sword ice so I'm hoping
after the fighting has ended he could do
the right thing and leave that sword
with the Starks that's assuming he's
still alive after the war but I'm not so
sure Jamie's gonna survive this war he's
not really capable of defending himself
anymore the only reason why he has
survived this long is that a pure look
in his Valyrian steel Plaut armor this
also puts Jamie in position of
fulfilling a prediction I made several
months ago now that Jamie is going north
he could end up sacrificing himself for
one of the Starks in order to complete
his own Redemption arc if Jamie has to
die that would be a great way for him to
go by putting himself on the line for
someone else someone that he had wronged
in the past but we will see the stage is
also being set for another redemption or
to be completed in season eight and this
is another prediction I have made ever
since spoiler photos came out showing
your Greyjoy being a prisoner of euron
greyjoy
Theon will take his small rescue team
and attempt to save Yara just like Yara
tried to save Theon back when Ramsay had
him as his captive but I have a feeling
Theon will be a little bit more
successful I
some of you completely disagree with me
about this but I believe Theon will
complete his arc by putting his own life
on the line while attempting to set yar
free and in the process he will go
head-to-head with his uncle yer on Theon
may die trying and I can easily see that
happening but if he does he will die
doing something heroic for his sister
who he abandoned back in Episode two
there is only one season left which
means every single characters arc will
come to a close whether you believe it
or not this is Theon zark just like I
believe Jamie's Ark will be for one of
those Starks this story began with Jamie
pushing a stark out of the window and I
think his story may end by saving one of
the Starks in that person most likely
being bran Stark in some way but keep in
mind I know nothing it's gonna be
interesting to see what all they are
able to fit into this story during
season eight with only six episodes left
I truly am hoping they do make each
episode around 90 plus minutes like they
said they wanted to do there is still a
lot of story left to be told and even
with all of its flaws I am still very
excited to see how things turn out in
the end let me know what you think about
some of these ideas do you agree with
what I said or do you think things will
play out differently leave your thoughts
or questions down below I want to thank
everyone so much for stopping by to
watch the video I really do appreciate
that along with everyone who supports me
on patreon have a great day everyone
I'll see you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]